what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and marvel pulled a fast
one on us they dropped the doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
trailer before the super bowl we thought
it was going to come out during but it
looks like that's probably going to be
moon night and stuff like that but they
just dropped the official trailer so
let's watch it
i'm so excited about this one
night
i dreamed the same dream
the nightmare begins you said nightmare
i did what i had to do
[Music]
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
[Music]
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
[Music]
no no no we should tell him the truth
oh my gosh
that is patrick stewart's voice
no
things just got out of hand
[Music]
captain marvel
you
[Music]
oh my gosh
that doesn't seem fair
oh my gosh
no wait look at that hold on
yo that we're going back that was
patrick stewart's voice and that was all
right here
i can't are you trying to see the
outline
of
people tell
and you can see it's freaking him right
there dude it's freaking patrick stewart
you can tell just from the silhouette in
the background his bald head oh my gosh
oh my gosh that is literally patrick
stewart and those chairs are for the
multiversal illuminati which i've been
talking about for a super long time we
should tell him the truth oh my gosh
okay
we're not ready for this movie i think i
think i think this movie truly is going
to be madness oh my gosh let me know
what you think about this trailer in the
comments down below i'm going to do a
full breakdown about this tomorrow a lot
to dissect but wow
i'm so excited about this wow comment
below what you think don't forget to
like the video and subscribe and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woofwoof we are not ready for
this